well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
parliamentary sketch writer
madeleine grant and the investigations
editor at open democracy peter gagan
lovely to see you both and welcome
first of all front pages then let's
start with the sun leading with
the golfing legend tiger woods in
surgery following that car accident in
california
the metro leading with the potential of
vaccine passports where access to venues
and businesses
may require proof of a covert 19 jab
tiger was also pictured as you can see
the telegraph reports
restrictions could be lifted sooner than
expected
if real world data on the vaccine
rollout
shows large improvements calls for the
vaccine to be offered door-to-door
according to the guardian to stop kovid
becoming
a disease of the poor a sharp rise in
northern tourism since the prime
minister's announcement
of a road map out of lockdown that's the
lead story for the yorkshire post
the uptake in tourism following the
release of the road map
has been dubbed the great british
takeoff by the daily mirror
the express leading on the same story
calling it
a stampede for the great getaway
meanwhile the financial times reports
there is hope the u.s
markets will return to normal this year
so we're joined then by madeleine grant
peter gagan welcome then to both of you
uh let's kick off with the metro show
with this idea of passports to a normal
life
um the prime minister madeleine today
talking about the complexities
and the ethical questions about this um
what does the metro say and what's your
reading of this
the metro says that the prime minister
has tasked uh michael gove
his great brexit chief to look seriously
at these proposals
and they are slightly distinct from what
we've heard previously about vaccine
passports because these wouldn't be the
kind uh where you would simply showing
proof of vaccination in order to travel
abroad or to admit passages
from abroad into britain this would be
for you know aspects of work life and
civil life so things like workplaces
pubs restaurants
um and to you know determine if you can
take part in these kinds of activities
and and my reading visual i mean i must
say i find it all
a bit curious actually when you consider
um the extraordinary
take-up of the vaccine in the country
far more than
our medical experts and ministers were
expecting and you consider how
the extraordinary success with the
vaccination roll out it won't actually
be that long until
we have vaccinated you know large sways
of the population so just an interesting
time to be considering bringing in
what would be a big national
infrastructure of
uh certification to allow you to do
everyday activities and also a kind of
change to our way of life you know
previously the assumption has been that
you can go to places but now to kind of
show proof in order to enter a venue um
i mean i find it rather
rather curious myself yeah it's almost
the antithesis of freedoms as we know it
isn't it
the prime minister described it as a
novelty
for our country and some suggestion that
it could be via an app for example
uh tonight i see and but he was very
concerned about those elements of
society who
for whatever reason don't get vaccinated
maybe even for medical reasons
communities that so far have not been
targeted and peter there are some
really big questions aren't there about
those who are getting left behind in
terms of vaccines and the implications
for them
yes we already know we've seen lots of
statistics about people in the bme
community lower uptakes
but also some people just can't get
vaccinated as you mentioned for health
reasons
but thankfully so far it looks like the
number of people who won't take the
vaccine because they're opposed to it
the bounty tax people
is quite low actually we don't have the
same problem that lots of other european
countries seem to have
but there's by the same there's going to
be a lot of people who for various
reasons will be able
to to be vaccinated so you can see why
the government's trying to think about
is there
to kind of work around these people so
that we don't end up with a large
swathed population
who could be susceptible because we
still don't know what herd immunity that
phrase we've been hearing about for a
year almost what the number
numbers for herd immunity actually are
because it does it varies by different
types of diseases and viruses
so we don't know whether it's seventy
percent eighty percent ninety percent
ninety five percent
for for covert nineteen so there's a lot
of uncertainty i can understand why the
government is looking
at this and clearly it's quite it seems
to be reasonably early days but
judging by some of the reports we're
hearing that they might be able to use
some of the apps that exist for booking
tests and things like that so
clearly they are thinking about what
infrastructure might be needed to do
this if it was to happen
let's just go to the guardian then
because it's kind of related from what
we talked about
this is a call for vaccines to be given
at home to stop covert becoming a
disease of the poor
and this would presumably be in certain
communities you could literally go bang
bang bang and have everybody done
do you think that would be accepted by
people do you think um madeline is that
is that an answer do you think to get
some
some people because i had jonathan
ashworth talking today about we could
end up with 40 to 50 percent of people
who don't get the vaccine if 20
to children for 10 percent of people
it's not efficacious
10 people don't get vaccinated you soon
get up to quite big numbers don't you
yeah you do and that would start to
impact the r rate and perhaps the rate
at which we can unlock
the country i mean this is a very
interesting proposal in the guardian
because
i don't think it's currently something
that government has done or
is has publicly said that they're
considering but um the ceo
of the running me trust has urged the
government and i'm sure others have as
well
to start going door-to-door into areas
of very low take-up
now where i think they may run into a
problem here is that they've already
as peter quite rightly said we don't
have the same kind of problem of
kind of anti-vaxx feeling in the country
and the government has also
already done a lot of information
campaigns they've they've done a lot to
try
to reach these areas and i do suspect
that perhaps when you do
uh if you're sending people door-to-door
which is what they've been arguing for
that there will still be some people who
refuse and you know short of
we i don't it depends if you want to
live in that kind of society i
personally would not want to live in a
society where people
are being forced to take a job but i do
think given given the high stakes
you've got to throw the kitchen sink at
this and if there are areas where people
haven't received the information
then sending people door-to-door to
speed up that roll out um is
is definitely the right thing to do well
madeleine peters stay there we're just
going to
cross over to california to uh discuss
the story we'll come to later
the breaking news then that tiger woods
is in hospital following a car crash in
california
let's speak now to my colleague at nbc
jennifer bjorkland who's
outside the harbour ucla medical center
in los angeles county and a great deal
of concern
about tiger's condition what's the
latest you can bring us
anna we can tell you that we just heard
from hospital officials that he
is still in surgery so several hours
he's been in surgery
on his legs after that call came in
early this morning 7
12. two people we were told stopped
their cars when they saw what happened
and we're told that the fire crews
responding were able to get
tiger woods out of his crashed vehicle
pretty quickly by
popping out the windshield and pulling
him through now people in the area
this morning tell us it was not foggy it
was daylight at the time of the crash we
also know that law enforcement says
it does not appear that there was any
alcohol or any substance issues with
tiger woods although we know all of this
will be part of the broader
investigation what we do know about this
particular portion of road is that it's
curvy
and steep all at the same time and if
you're not familiar with the area you
can easily
miss a turn and lose control which may
have been what happened but that
investigation
underway as we do know that the 45 year
old golfing icon
is undergoing surgery on his legs
looking at the damage to the suv
that he was in it's not hard to imagine
how badly injured he could have been but
there's no official word
you know that he was alert and talking
to the first responders
this morning when they came to rescue
him he was on his way to the golf course
which had been reserved for golf digest
for a shoot that
was happening for a show that was
shooting yesterday and scheduled for
today and he was in town over the
weekend for the genesis
invitational a golf open that's played
every year here that he was the host of
he awarded the trophy was in good
spirits and talking about how
he was hoping that he was well enough
recovered from back surgery
a few weeks ago to be able to play in
the masters starting on april 8th and of
course now that's all derailed as he is
in surgery
at this hour here at harbor ucla medical
center anna yes and
certainly the masters have paid tribute
to him and wished him their very best as
do
we jennifer thank you very much today
jennifer brookland
outside the hospital which is currently
treating tiger woods
and peter as we heard that makes the
front page of a number of newspapers the
guardian
the metro uh the sun as well i'm clearly
still in surgery and we we do wish him
well don't we peter
yes of course and the image the images
are quite you know we know we had the
jaws of light
a kind of almost oxymoronic term for the
kind of
when you do have a smash like that you
can see in the front page of the sun and
you can there's
we've already seen this evening more
images from the scene it does look like
a really horrific crash and
you know it is an incredible career it's
a career that spans you know over 25
about 25 years at this stage it's had
lots and lots of highs and lows
and and you know this is in some ways
you know he won the masters again
a couple of years ago for the first half
who had kind of a
huge and a deer in his career from about
20 000 910 so
he has a he's a figure and a sportsman
he's
kind of had a checkered past and this is
in some ways if he
walks out of that crash it would be um
you know looks
it looks very serious so hopefully it
isn't as serious as it looks and he will
be able to come back again
yes absolutely so still in surgery with
multiple
leg injuries as you say uh fingers
crossed uh he is okay uh we'll certainly
keep an eye on that story
um stay back stand by lots more still to
come we'll have the very latest on
uh sturgeon vs sam well welcome back
you're watching the press preview with
me now parliamentary sketch writer
madeline grant
and the investigations editor at open
democracy peter gagan welcome to both of
you
and let's go to the financial times now
a picture there of nicola sturgeon
it's got kind of interesting hasn't it
in scotland between
her the snp and her predecessor
obviously alex salmond
and we are not now going to hear
evidence from him tomorrow peter
explain the significance of this if you
can
yes well tomorrow that's a big ask
because this has been one of these
rolling stories that's been going you
know
it's been going on almost for years in
scotland but we thought that tomorrow we
might get a bit more clarity because
alex simon was due
to appear before a scottish parliament
committee
that was looking into the kind of the
the ali the kind of
investigation into the allegations
around him so you know i'm sure some
viewers remember about this time last
year alex almond was cleared at the high
court in edinburgh of a series of
charges
but what's going what's been going on is
a long-running investigation
into the scottish government's
investigation alex hammond
from a year earlier which was found to
be unlawful
and this all the occur basically alex
simon had
uh been poised to give evidence on this
but he's pulled out
he's alleging there's been a conspiracy
by his former colleagues by his
former number two his protege nicholas
sturgeon
and senior members of the snp and he was
due to give this evidence but
he's pulled out because um basically
um it was because there was a submission
that was
published on the scottish government
website on monday on monday evening
was then removed from the scholarship
website and kind of
six sections of this 35 section
submission were redacted alexander said
he can't give his evidence with those
redactions in place
and there's now talk that it could be uh
some reports even though it could be
he could still give in a pic to make an
appearance on friday
and the expectation was that if alex
salmond appeared nicolas sturgeon would
then appear and this story that's been
in some ways a kind of
a tinder box waiting to really uh blow
you know really kind of take fire in
scotland uh would
would do so once alex hammond appears so
it's been another
a twist in this story and it's still
uncertain if simon will appear
yes and just and just briefly madeline
everyone looking at whether people in
scotland care about this because of
course we've got elections in may
which seem to have deeper significance
don't they in terms of
independence and uh and the future of
scotland yeah that's absolutely right
it's been you know
the snp doesn't generally need um need
much encouragement to see something as a
sign that independence is the answer to
all of scotland's problems um but they
they were very much hoping for
an absolute electoral whitewash the uh
at the
um at the upcoming elections but
actually this is really starting to land
i've
saw a poll tonight that had them down by
i think 10 or 11
uh percentage points in the in the
opinion polls which is is
truly fascinating and also fascinating
as peter said to see how
something that's been going on for a
long time something that began as
more of a kind of bitter personal
struggle between
these two titans of the snp has kind of
morphed into something
that indicates a much greater sense of
cronyism at the heart of scottish
politics you know that
critics are alleging that the crown
office which is scotland's prosecuting
authority
has become a kind of glorified wing of
the snp um after refusing to
reveal evidence that alex simon says is
crucial to his case
and demanding these large-scale
redactions um which they do
they do um claiming that this would um
this would perhaps um compromise the
anonymity of
some of the compliments in his case but
actually that information has been
available in the public domain
for some time and it doesn't appear to
do that at all
which has led many people to question
you know were they simply told to do
this
by by the smp to what extent is there um
meddling going on in the kind of
judicial functions of scotland
from the scottish national party so it
has the potential to
really uh really create some waves even
in a country where
the snp has been in in the ascendancy
for such a long time
yes indeed indomitable i mean one
wonders whether the disappointment over
the
scottish unlockdown is partly feeding
into those figures as well
the herald i see is it says outcry of a
sturgeon's
uh too cautious lockdown exit plan and
meanwhile the daily mirror
in terms of england the great british
takeoff they say lockdown weary sun
seekers
spark holiday bookings boom the
yorkshire post as well hope's rising for
an upsurge in tourism we've got about
10 seconds left peter are you feeling
more optimistic for
oh no you don't even have that i've
overrun i will see you at half past
eleven never mind
thank you both very much indeed